c'est une petite boutique au cette route
de trouville voilà vingt ans maintenant
que la chiffo s'inscrit en toutes
lettres dans le tissu social canet cette
structure emploie jusqu'à 50 une
personne en contrat à durée déterminée
d'insertion
encadrés par six salariés permanents
vous êtes au coeur de l'atelier
d'insertion socioprofessionnelle
annie claire elle est arrivée à la
chiffo 11 septembre dernier poussé cette
porte c'est ma fierté de travailler de
l'endroit du titre c'est très important
pour eux comme presque tous les matins
après être passé par la case casier
direction la pointeuse avant de recevoir
les premières consignes du jour vous
allez être en boutique
emeline et orly aussi à 52 ans à nice
vient de voir son cdd contrat à durée
déterminée d'insertion pour renouveler
20 heures par semaine payées au smic
c'est peu et beaucoup à la fois c'est
important de dire de john cage à
week-end
c'est important de dire j'ai une cour
une journée de congé j'ai des vacances
pour moi c'est important vous travaillez
mais vous mais vous avez vos week-ends
vous avez vous que vous avez votre
salaire vous avez vous déjà ma fierté de
de travailler d'avoir un salaire d'avoir
pointé oui tant parler oui je
travaillerai comme la plupart de ses
collègues à la chiffo annick qu'est ce
que l'on appelle une cabossés de la vie
ou de ces femmes qui ont un jour vécu
une sortie de route professionnelle vous
avez une carte de fidélité
j'ai eu un décès qui m'a complètement
bouleversée donc suite à tous à part
on va dire que je suis un petit peu aux
enfers depuis cinq mois elle vit donc sa
présence au sein de cette structure
comme une véritable renaissance ce
sentiment d'être utile aux autres et à
soi-même
d'ailleurs au bout de son contrat il y a
en projet à mener à bien mon projet
c'est travailler près des personnes sans
domicile fixe début du mini j'espère que
j'arrivais à avoir ma prochaine j'espère
je me bats parce que ça fait perdre le
vide
ça me fait plus personnel j'ai déjà avec
lui ça fait encore peur maintenant
l'important ben voilà c'est de
revaloriser les compétences de travail
et la confiance en soi
et puis les outils pour aller vers
l'employeur et certaines techniques ça
on nous les personnes nous les apprend
les études nous les apprennent pas et du
coup nous on est là pour ça de la
logistique en passant par l'atelier ou
bien encore la boutique à la chiffo
polyvalence rime avec confiance demain
nous en prendrons le circuit de la
collecte des vêtements